hello and welcome to the new world
review your selves for everything anime
and manga and today we're here to talk
about attack on Titan season 3 now in
classic new world review style yesterday
and late to this series not attack on
Titan but season 3 specifically and it's
because I have a very strange
relationship with attack on Titan
because I watched the first series when
it was airing loved it then tried the
manga and hated it because the art
really was not for me not bashing the
art just saying that it was something
that I never grew accustomed to and then
I just forgot about it because there
wasn't another enemy for what four years
when season 2 came out I watched it and
it was good yeah but I feel like it
really lost that zing that originally
caught me and as a result I took my
sweet time with season 3 but I have to
say that as a result I am incredibly
pleasantly surprised i sat down to watch
it thinking that it was just time to do
my duty as an anime fan and then I uh
well I just didn't stop season 3 really
managed to recapture some of that morbid
magic that the first anime outing had
and before we go any further this is
your spoiler warning I am more than
likely going to talk about very specific
events so bear that in mind but first up
the thing that struck me the most is
obviously the beautiful animation which
studio is a pretty damn incredible group
as they continue to demonstrate with the
ongoing Vinland soccer anime which I'm
also loving but in this case I am
convinced that they have elevated tackle
on Titan beyond anything the original
manga could have dreamed
once again that's just my opinion like
for example when I did try to read the
manga I got up to the end of the first
half of the season with Aaron being
captured again and all the historian of
and in the manga I vividly remember
being bored whilst reading this which is
why afterwards I would have dropped it
and that clearly isn't a fault of the
storytelling but the presentation
because season 3 is the anime takes the
very same material and manages to keep
me incredibly invested with stunning
aesthetic storytelling and in particular
I find myself captivated by pretty much
any action scene in season 3 but even in
the solo moments of which there are an
abundance especially in the first half
the art is just so slick and sleek and
it's hard to describe but it presents
such an incredibly solid image it's so
easy to watch and the anime takes
advantage of lighting as well crafting
beautiful sunsets terrifying darkness
and apocalyptic battle conditions and I
guess what I'm trying to say is that
every shot in this series
feels incredibly rich as opposed to a
more classic anime style which can be
very flat and you know that works for a
lot of shows but I am glad that we're
going a step further here in terms of
the visual
one negative I will say is that I'm
still not keen on the CGI whatsoever so
yes I'm one of those people like the
whole portion with the colossal Titan
wall amazing was a bit iffy in the
moments where CGI was used to bring it
to life it just looks super clunky not
natural at all and most importantly not
threatening because it looks like a
university animated students project and
yeah that does not apply universally
there were some sequences where it did
look alright but that was primarily due
to the camera work rather than the
actual CGI itself just drop the CGI it
does not belong in this world
and it always somewhat breaks my
immersion because it's such a stark
contrast to the beautiful 2d art and
animation on display otherwise and you
know what in a series of lesser 2d
quality yeah you could probably get away
with this kind of CGI but not attack on
Titan but hey at least it's not berserk
now I have to say that in retrospect the
thing I enjoyed most about season 3 was
finally getting some answers to the
story rather than just obtaining more
questions I mean yeah mysteries are the
spice of series like this but they can
only last so long and I'm thrilled that
we are finally getting into the meat of
things and some of the best and most
heartbreaking episodes of season 3 what
the ones have focused on krish's
memories and of course I give full
credit to the manga here because this
section of story was spectacular and it
gave me a whole new appreciation for
Titans that I never thought I'd be
capable of feeling I mean just watching
these episodes made me feel absolutely
enraged and it was a massive punch in
the gut which was assisted by fantastic
vocal performances some wonderful
Twilight lighting at the site of
paradise and unbelievably emotive music
as well as very intentional moments of
atmospheric silence that assists the
intimacy of these scenes a lot and also
just as a side note wow do I definitely
hate Zeke as a result so before all of
this I was pretty much indifferent to
his existence as the beast Titan and he
was pretty terrifying and kind of cool
but his flashback actually makes me
flashback
to the point in the season where Levi
had the chance to end him for good and I
understand why narrative Lee anyway he
couldn't die here because Zeke
ultimately holds some sort of importance
to Aaron as they came from the same
source of jeers as I guess but I do feel
like attack on Titan is just full of
these moments where victory is as simple
as one tiny action and then some sort of
ridiculous mental block just stops at
happening each time in fact the exact
same thing went on to happen with Reiner
when John prolonged his life and then
later broke down and yelled it's all my
fault
and in that moment I was just like yes
yes it is all your fault and I do get
the basic
idea was to steal their powers as well
as having some complex thought behind it
like Levi wanting to save Ellen and John
just having feelings for a former
comrade but for God's sake these Titans
just killed almost 200 Scouts and they
will inevitably cause such bloodshed
again the next time you meet them in
battle
so take the loss on the Titan powers and
end it here and that's actually why I
was so glad that Bertolt actually had a
conclusion because there was a while
there where it was taking an awfully
long time for things to happen and I
thought he may have been able to escape
as well but instead we got one of the
greatest moments of the series when he
was eaten by Titan Arman and it's weird
because yeah I did feel sorry for Bert
old but then I remembered the staggering
amount of people that he had mercilessly
killed and then you know everything was
okay I'm also really glad that it
happened because tackle on Titan has a
really weird character dynamic I find
that they're either generally so squishy
and expendable that they are literally
made to die or they're completely
immortal and can never be killed no
matter how bad a situation gets and an
example of characters like that would be
corny Oh Sasha I love both of them but
the only reason they survived this
season was because they are secondary
protagonists there were individuals far
more skilled and experienced who were
wiped out instantly and it does get a
bit plot armory to having to keep
believe that Wow of the nine survivors
they all happen to be our main cast
again except one which was actually a
nice surprise
good old flock but that's why it was
nice to see that line get crossed by
taking care of a major character like
Bertolt even if he is an antagonist
because he did feel like one of those
untouchable characters so it introduced
a brief period of expendability amongst
the main cast and we brought him up
briefly before but let's talk about
Arman for a bit this guy was the star of
my favorite episode of the season being
here the moment of almond sacrifice was
so for want of a better word heroic and
I don't mean that in the traditional
coming to the rescue kind of way but
didn't though this is everything I can
do and if it cost me my life and that's
fine kind of way of all of the main
characters in the season I feel like
almond stands out and received by far
the most gwyrth although to be fair I
don't think he has a lot of competition
I mean Mikasa look I honestly struggled
to remember a single thing she did this
season for a primary protagonist she
spent a lot of time in the background or
just quietly standing beside Aaron and
as for Aaron himself I've honestly never
cared for him and I wasn't about to stop
now he's just too intense for my liking
you know always yelling in
the early days noise crying and
depressed in these days that get it he's
been through unimaginable experiences
that would crumble the mind of any
average person but I get really bored
when it's just him on screen wallowing
in his own
pitov Aaron feels so I reckon just make
him a secondary protagonist and let's
promote Levi two main protagonists and
speaking of Levi it was awesome as
always this character stole attack on
Titan the moment he was introduced and
as expected he provides another
phenomenal spectacle this season with a
completely one-sided fight against the
Beast Titan and Wow I rewatched that
saying like seven times after the
episode ended it's so good and his
flashback was also done really well
because even though I knew it was going
to happen the anime still made me feel
everything I needed to which was a ton
of sympathy a little disgust and a
healthy serving of what the hell this
world is dark and that goes for the
entire series really I think it did
everything it needed to do and more to
provide a fantastic viewing experience
in an incredibly immersive world driving
ever forward towards its conclusion and
as a result for the first time in a very
long time I'm actually looking forward
to more attack on Titan so bring on
season four in 2020 if that pretty much
does it for my thoughts on season 3 of
attack on Titan if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produce in general then please do
consider donating to the ground line
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
both channel and incredible amount and
if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discourse over where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on the season 3 of attack
on Titan this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
[Music]